this is the second try for this dream
and I hope this is staying stable now
and that would be really excellent if it
yeah this is the case so let's see what
we got here
I'm on again now why am i standard
internet connection which is really ok
once it works it either works or it
doesn't and if it works it also should
work with the settings for the stream
like 60fps I hope everything is this is
fine now you hear me all right you see
me all right and I'm going to play
viewers but I'm going to be on the
lookout what happens here in my upload
speed is actually not too bad it just it
just wants to work in the first place
yeah but I hope that things will be will
be better and I get the new provider
soonish yeah so what I wanted to say is
that interestingly enough we have a new
player on HS yes but wonderful but not
as much and this is a world champion
Magnus Carlsen honest doctor drunken
steam and the years earlier played I
think some bullets German and if if he
is playing yeah I'm definitely
considering to do keep it safe yeah
that's always fun commencing the world
champion it's really really cool
I don't know if you if you watch that
but yesterday there was the protest
League and Magnus was streaming on his
own Ludwig hammers account and was doing
basically what I'm doing now here with
his pro chesley game
there was really really good fun very
interesting to listen to his thought
process he was really not amused about
his games he he felt he wasn't playing
well and this is for his standards
probably true okay so um what to do here
I'm not quite sure I like this position
I think I'm quite comfortable but
nothing special is going on can you
please give me a quick feedback if you
see and hear the stream all right
have not heard anything bad so I guess
it is okay
Stream is fun okay that's good I haven't
played well here this game against
Burleigh 22 have to admit especially
whoopsy it can be annoying
yeah that's a different a different idea
at the same time I have to get the Queen
out of this pin on the sea foul
maybe just play you form
yeah it's a bit it's a bit a bit of a
pain yeah that there is this b5m of
coming maybe this is an idea covering
the Queen and threatening Knight takes
Knight takes b6 and threat the variances
ask me how many hours have ever worked
today
not much can't see the stream though you
have to refresh I haven't I've worked
all that much today
actually we should 86 Wow yeah I can
take on b6 I mean this is a weird way to
play but yeah and we we take lots of
stuff here yeah the best coffee that I
got is actually wasn't done in Italy
yeah I absolutely I have nothing bad to
say about like French coffee that was
mentioned earlier but I really felt that
the coffee in its only was fantastic
I've only been to to Venice admittedly
and to some smaller places in the Italy
in close to the Slovenian bottom o
Kesava you resigned all things
yeah the connection issues should start
the best coffee ever got was made in
your kitchen from Foucault that's great
I'm really happy with my tea recently
but with all those issues near the
beginning of the stream I actually
wasn't even able I didn't even manage to
make myself some tea which is really
really bad I only got water now I don't
put any I don't put any milk in my team
it depends on the type of tea sometimes
I put in some some sweetener okay I'm
kind of freezing here don't know what to
do this 158 maybe but then I have 96 no
I don't like milk at all in the team
again sometimes I use a bit of sweetener
it's a thousand is playing only chess
what is he doing playing chess bras okay
okay now I should be in good shape
the pond is very dangerous what is that
actually three plus two okay
yeah I can't do commentary on Magnus's
games but his friend ultra bullet
against against the chest press out
reported yet doing commentary an ultra
bullet this is really a really really
funky idea okay would seem no I haven't
met any of the chest brass and I mean
okay of course I know Robin van Campen I
mean from back back in the day when he
was a junior but I I don't know him
personally I just think I'm Laden in the
Dutch league for for a long time so I
played against his team's more than once
when it's not like we're friends or
anything okay
well an echo in the microphone I don't
know why exactly this this complaint
I got not last time when i stream but
and it was probably not that great
actually I screwed this up pretty badly
pretty pretty badly not sure that I like
wins
but yeah so okay yeah I don't know with
the with the echo some people say they
have echo or some people say they don't
I don't know it's a bit weird yeah I
shouldn't won that game but anyway
so is he really playing Archer bullet
the whole time so let's have a look
Oh cubed see how a bullet is kind of
tough you know we can we can try and if
this is this is doable let's say but I'm
not sure so ok cozzens go to my gym and
yeah he's material down and they are
really kinky right very likely and wrong
but you can definitely always always
possible for commander yeah now Blake is
winning but - oh actually right hey when
did - a medium that was it was helpful
so we have an equal match and cosplay on
1g5 under on the first on the first move
my guess is very active I kind of wonder
how I am where the chest bras can
actually when they actually can play on
a chest because I should have an
exclusive contract was just on comm why
why are they actually allowed to play on
HS it's a bit weird okay so they are not
actually streaming this okay so yeah
this is a pretty equal position I think
maybe I would prefer my neck here like
it's a little bit more active 94 was a
nice shot and now I'm why just trying to
get active with F for young again black
like Y I would prefer here but it's ten
seconds I know that I would simply note
everything on time yeah this is just for
me this is too quick
yeah white is not winning 55 on the FL
and this is this is killing my twins
white wins a bunch of material check
check and language on time oh my
goodness yeah you know yesterday I mean
a thousand was streaming these games I
really felt okay what kind of fantastic
thing that is yeah if you just imagine
if we do a comparison with chess
and 20 years ago it's it's simply I mean
I'm thinking about I'd say that because
far-off would like explain this game's
life yeah back then it would be it would
be on TV of course and no internet and
yeah I cannot really scroll down I could
describe is currently slightly in favor
of Magnus let's - yeah
fortunately streaming would be the best
trash talk ever
oh my goodness it's a yeah what he did
is crazy
yeah here white Magnus is an exchange up
but of course the thing is kind of kind
of messy yeah it's you know I can't I
cannot really scroll down yeah it would
have to be just a whole board area
become to flavor blanket and it's
totally lost and when it's okay
no I'm gonna complain in the German
Amateur Chess Championships I think they
have some sort of limit what kind of
radar you need it was bad
yeah the Magnus is leading by am by one
point by two points of the session
actually
[Music]
yeah White has some compensation yeah I
was surprised that he - on d6 oh that
was a queen I was a bit surprised and
206 there I really I think opponent is
kind of that really yeah I'm kind of I
would rather have them play I'd say yeah
like you know all the bullet orbits it
has a bit more content I mean it's not
fun to watch this now shortened and
black cutting c3 and black it's again
very active here it's equal material no
black is one da porn and yeah black
black is better
absolutely in this position at the time
is extremely relevant I think that on
fact um then the sweet that Magnus s is
really really good I mean he's very
lucky cousin is blundered Wow he won on
time but it really I was a poor close
again and he's extremely fast extremely
fast Wow
it was born yeah right has the better
ending now it's a materialist equal yeah
it never be equal wow this is hanging
yes I just tried to win this but other
than the Big Buddha each coin is
extremely dangerous
yeah I think that will be moving tough
okay so what what has wrong position
wise yeah I know yeah he's so quick he's
got seven seconds left which is amazing
really yeah I can sacrifice the piece
and it's got quite a good attack I think
in hyperbole that that needs to count
for something
in fact he is one day eight eight the
hey drew
I still have hope I really gonna it
sounds so crazy fast that is really
amazing I mean okay this is going to be
made yeah okay Shannon is made but I
already know this echo it's it's tough
for me too yeah I mean my hearing is not
great and there's someone in the
Chettiar the HS Jetta saying hi Kara
will crush them both you know I don't
believe that the I always thought that
in in in Bullitt chess where it's no
increment that probably
Carroll would just be too quick but you
know it's hey man this is very very fast
I mean very fast so you are I'm not
really sure that you know proclick fast
and that he can't really would be much
quicker it's hard to say okay this is
this is this is very dangerous that
Kunia for now all kinds of things are
threatened I have 192 and so on
yeah Blackie Black has a huge attack
here and you should take a strong word
he's very annoying and it takes time to
fend off those those tricks and now what
I think has blunted the peace and lose
on time as a question if I ever have
plates Magnus
yeah in fact in fact I did I played some
blitz on the ice to see against Mosley
was when he was really really yeah young
like 10 11 12
this is this kind of this kind of age
and I know that I won games but also
lost games but a lot of games at the
time I was definitely the favorite in
those games but unit 1112 he was crazy
strong already yeah happy bullet is
indeed tough to comment on yeah but I
still think it's a it's got
entertainment to watching me giving an
odd odd remark yeah this is just a
picnic fest no black is ahead in terms
of time and position so Carla's leading
this by three points a smash Oh what
that was a very weird very weird moves
here yeah yeah he blitz of course yeah I
played blitz against Magnus on here as
you see they're not these games are lost
yeah I definitely know what I play
because back then I thought that account
was a fake one yet he was going to
believe that some some kid named Magnus
from Norway is any good yeah but he was
yeah maybe I will play some games later
on I don't know how many oh this is a
funny major the great major yeah who
cares six and made on f6
maybe I'm play some games later we don't
know how long they're going to are going
to play oh that's a weird setup by what
but at least you can make many moves
quite quickly
[Music]
yeah I actually think that this is not
too bad for white I know the Queen gets
in trouble yeah okay Magnus is better
he's got to two minor pieces for milk
and a much more active position okay
why should win Knight f6 check is an
idea okay it didn't happen I mean he six
or this one yeah the rookie saying when
they form in the Queen eggs okay I will
pretty clean
Yeah right now he has a pretty it's a
pretty good initiative for the porn but
you know you have to plea play really
really really quickly in 9f six doesn't
really do much
oh nice combination with Knight f6 at
the end oh and yeah Eric I think is
playing what is it should should be
winning it looks pretty awful the rook
on h7 is extremely extremely funny Queen
takes an avid Magnus is very very fast
so I know yes defend it is it's crazy
how many moves I make oh my god the best
technical playing platform is probably
really niche as yeah I think this is the
consensus it has the least lack end and
other technical glitches ICC actually is
is pretty strong in terms of like lack
and other things just that the
software's very very outdated but if you
don't mind that was the old software I
see is fine I mean it's it's it's quick
there's a little lag and this is really
okay and the player food is strong but
yeah the software is like from the 80s
yeah so what is this yeah probably White
has running a tech oops oops chief was
hanging was check is G take another take
site have a day crazies got seven
seconds left yeah this is crazy
so this is free in role of now from a
Magnus unsurprisingly the drawing that's
pretty low okay so what is this it's a
it's a pawn up ending actually for white
and now he's winning an exchange and
buses winning but you still have to do
it technically speaking politique take
quite a while
black ice passer but somehow he doesn't
have a fortress that would be wrong but
okay now now he's breaking through yeah
you should have six for the d6 was made
but yeah yeah you cannot really analyze
those games you can give the odd remark
but it's yeah it's it's clearly they
have to be some mistake let's say it's
impossible - don't - don't have that
yeah so yeah erik has broken this this
is run the series now Magnus won three
and now Eric is on the scoreboard again
and this position seems good for black
but it's not easy to play the night is
so tricky 97 is a shot
yes I saw that one once in a while
yeah this is actually a good good remark
by Mac if I take my sleeping habits
seriously of your leg stump does it
affect your chest I think it does some
people are less of a lesson let's say
then less likely to let's say meat
that's not made to tell much okay some
people are less likely to be affected by
that I think but some some arm and I
never play that well if I ever sleep
isn't great okay so that was the night
if we make this abundant tonight on h5
okay yeah okay that was a pretty bad
game public so Eric has won three in a
row
yeah yes he's back there did I get a $25
donation I didn't see it did I get one I
didn't see it
who did today's help I didn't see it I'm
sorry if I didn't okay so yeah it was
good for white anonymous okay yeah
thanks for subscribing best judge okay
this is actually good I can give more
information on my the repertoire that's
going to be released on chesil my 1.e4
repertoire for under Roe from Erika
that's that's a run I mean II Magnus
this is good but doesn't have this
stamina right in the sir in this kind of
format
minions clear that hands it is very very
strong at those time for trouble say we
have to see he's probably in those time
controls like probably top five in the
world or something like that maybe more
I don't know one expert on these kind of
things it is definitely very strong and
it looks like he's winning yeah get
another game
why dennis is Eric is is up rook now and
Wow
that's five in a row here Magnus has to
get his act together somehow
so information on that repertoire on the
e4 repertoire and I'm completely
finished with writing yeah everything is
ready but what we going to do is we're
releasing this our chasuble in the chess
about format so you cannot use the
learning software that chasuble has as
interactive book kind of learning
concept but there will also be a video
yeah this is the big change the video
will be fantastically really Eliza's a
lot embedded into the software and I
have to record those videos
and this means there's still some work
to do so we're not talking about a month
yeah it's probably going to be released
already much I said yeah I have to
record video and it's probably going to
be 10 to 12 hours of video and yeah that
is quite a bit that you need to do I
think Eric is going six and roam now yes
six in a row wow what the heck yeah his
cousin going to quit they're here after
six in a row or is he going to try to
try to get back okay try to get back
how's he doing it no something something
like that look serious yeah it looks
like it's obvious opening not some
rubbish let's say maybe he really wants
to stop this him it's something that you
saw yesterday under in the stream for
the prom Chesley I mean he's very
relaxed and stuff there it is he's a
pretty relaxed person when he's doing
doing the games but he's very critical
of his own moves column and he played
some some optimum moves for his standard
them I mean it's not like I'm not saying
I would have played better
don't get me wrong this is no I'm saying
with this wasn't grade and this was
thanks for the donation yeah up here son
I was very critical about some of his
play and he's extremely ambitious yeah
it's not the kind of person who okay he
broke the streak it's not the kind of
person who just like accepts that oh
that doesn't work out yeah he really
wants to do well and yeah get some yeah
puts really everything into it yeah so
he starts out kind of relaxed but if he
feels mmm man that doesn't go too well
then he is going to yeah really put put
in effort him okay this is looking very
good for white actually completely
winning objectively speaking when we're
talking hyper bullet and but like black
has maybe some chances on the Kim oh
yeah yeah there will be chances on the
king dark squares are very weak man the
bishop only three is extremely strong so
this is very good for Magnus and he will
probably win this quite clearly yes plus
he's got them
so two in a row for him so that gives
the whole standing to my mom roughly
being roughly equal now you have to see
the end they want one game before this
matches a man should actually still plus
one for Magnus and he's got a really
nice position
he's down upon but what what about the
whole Center here
yeah that's it's a winning position for
like blacks position was quite terrible
you know c5 and ninety seven meters in
its content on the cards one made on g7
which is to zero in rated games knows
where that's made ninety seven checkmate
yeah there was impossible to defend
yeah I know this is three in a row
before four cards and so then this very
strictly to smash em you don't see this
here maybe a client on scroll yeah so it
was three in a row for Magnus then six
for Eric and then three for mangas again
okay somehow we lost their focus and
what is that so cousin is I was cutting
on getting getting this piece onto f4
but there is no attack orally yeah
there's no attack
yeah why does it open
oh yeah playing for like weed to III
after the capture machi wonder what
should work okay then also we were the
queen is saying yeah wide wins
[Music]
yeah I think we're we're following again
so 93 here on that's actually if
underrated opening there's less lots of
trans positions with 193 but it's
actually quite interesting so not better
than the frequency of usage suggests a
move that is played so rarely you would
think is pretty bad but it's actually
quite okay yeah a very good position
here now here for for Eric good black
very good for Blackie
okay the worst is over properly for
white this is a tech looked almost
crushing but now it's just an endgame
with two extra points for Blackie and
coldness five seconds five seconds as a
lot okay I wouldn't suggest playing
Knights if we fall over the broad chest
all the time but it's its most in
transposition and you can you can play
it it's not totally terrible there are
some interesting ideas 'm to i
considered to play this one say as a
surprise but it's if you play one year
for it's not a big deal there's some
there's some things that are quite quite
similar okay so my heaven wow that is
fine it was a risky pre-move very risky
pre-war after 93 d5 yeah you can go on
e4 you can also play d4 f4 for the
Jabara opening later anyway so what is
that black is a queen down for rook and
seven seconds which is rather important
this is also not super easy for white to
play because black is somewhat
coordinated okay f6 okay now now white
is fresh on through there should be some
sort of made black it's got some current
playing there with the rook no and white
lost some time and it wasn't so easy it
wasn't so easy so
yeah magma sea going for each from heck
attack I'm not sure Carson does have
some contract with chest okay
I really don't I mean obviously it's
great on this on teacher so it cannot
probably be a contract but I am a little
bit in case of from chest for us because
they they definitely have something
signed with chest so calm
yeah there's wind from black so they're
not trading your blow for blow I think
it's how they would call it and it
matches equal sixteen point five both
yes probably it's a problem
yeah pointless for somebody like magnets
cause net to make some sort of contract
which is uncommon when they prominent
yes I mean he's got enough money already
if I would retire and I mean of course
you always like to earn more but yeah I
really don't care if they pay you some
some of them thousand dollars young if
you can have fun yeah playing on the
side way you want to play and when
whatever you want to play it some so no
I'm not I'm personally not considering
to sign a contract with just sort
compromise dreams it's um I'm streaming
on DTS because I do all this everything
ready on on that side I do
my lessons on HS and it would feel
really weird to for me to stream or
chest or call me when little on that
side yeah I haven't blocked on there for
ages and I really don't I really don't
feel I should suit you from them yeah
this position here is a bit better for
white I think maybe not maybe not but
the time will tell ya my winsome mangas
wins what the heck okay oh my that's
really cool yeah within the speed there
that that then that they both have is
really remarkable and I know it sounds a
bit funny I mean I personally I don't
feel that would yeah for from my age to
be honest but I know that it has
something to do with age I could
absolute I'll never play that quick
maybe I could have done so 20 years ago
but today absolutely absolutely you know
no way that I could could be that quick
with the Morrow's it's impossible
yeah here kasnia's gone how many parts
for parts for the piece yeah yeah like
like boom like it's not completely
winning in the end time was it was good
as well so Magnus is getting the upper
hand there in the last couple of games
and okay so no Eric somehow has to get
get back in this
yeah I think yeah this is easier from
black to black now I don't know how we
going to price that you for each one
it's very good for black the solution
and then sacrifices comment all the
pieces are super active now I don't know
if Nakamura I haven't played on HS I
don't really know
it's possible certainly possible but he
was always more of an ICC guy before he
switched to to that exclusive contract
with Chester cold yeah Magnus is just
quicker than then that Hansen this is
crazy
I won five in a row that's amazing yeah
now now he's a poner and he's a really
really nice position yeah very well my
centralised position
if yeah this looks like God is going to
win this one this is going to be major
check and takes a fine and that's
probably some kind of made coming
yep and this is something six in row for
the world champion you should play more
this is a fun stream I don't have to do
anything it's just really really nice a
I'm watching watch on the plane
I mean again I would like to I would
have liked to have a somewhat somewhat
less route or time travel but it's it's
it's what it is it's it's it's so often
about flow now in those kind of super
quick time technical let's give up the
cooling down yeah it's not easy for my
to convert this it's all promise and oh
that could be made and I - not managing
a medium super quick he's so quick Wow
no I think yeah link on some eric is
doing better than I thought he would I'm
not sure this this is 30 second chassis
and he's extremely good at that so okay
here white is a lot better town has got
a tan along now seven in a row
and this looks very strong again and why
is just a piece of another
winning attack yeah I think being in
line back in your mid forties you had
someone I mean at least them I feel
somewhat slower than I was some yes some
years ago I don't feel it's like a lot
but there is a difference but so it
depends so much especially when when you
when you have creature controls it
depends a lot on on what that how that
day works out for you sometimes listen I
see three si ng fibers hanging are very
very interesting for black to play the
sacrifice it's got it much better
coordination yeah you know I mean I
think that there are there are days oh
that's made and that's the end of the
series yeah Eric has broken up broken
this is run run this word out and there
are still days when everything works
very very well in intuitive controls for
example and there are many examples like
honor to serve the world-record champion
an aged 40 48 or 49 I'm not quite sure
about the exact date when he was born
his 1960 1969
what I really feel gets gets worse is
some with ages reaction time and this
that's head like doing this doing this
with quick mouse movement yeah this is
really getting most okay what is the
corner photon of nights here
yeah should only avoid still means can
always help no stalemate I draw wow this
is this was pretty nice for black
Oh what the heck
this is extremely lucky yeah Kasparov
retired as a read as a quite quite early
age now he retired at 41 or 42 not
exactly sure 42 I think and of course
but if he would have continued to play
as a professional player he would also
be very clearly in the top ten that is
really not much about it okay then we
had yeah Mendes winning and sitting by
eight yeah okay this is good good open
Inquisition for black but reasonably
solid nice shot 95 oops look see see
that one that was great yeah okay so
black now is a pizza and this is real
yeah Mac says doesn't like the chat
control
I completely understand this is not for
everybody but it's it's a pretty I mean
at least for the moment a pretty rare
thing yet to have the opportunity to do
a leach s broadcast and then see Magnus
playing I mean as I mentioned I would
have liked to have a longer time control
but it's just how they play and yeah
time going again for the power champion
I mean it's just you think that he has
played less
online bullet chest simply because when
he has to play all those big tournaments
and like yeah improve his classical time
control chess so it's not like played
all the time on the internet playing
bullet chess or yeah I'll triple it or
whatever and well I mean Eric Hanson I
mean it's not doing that all the time
but he has a fair amount of those games
they're playing those tournaments only
chest arenas whatever and if you feel
good just by from experience you should
be ahead there in some way and cars in
the food have all that much experience
of those tab controls so it doesn't feel
like that I was just so quick I know
he's position is lost but that is far
from for the seconds up you made there
very trooper was very quick okay so
gambit opening here yeah I mean
obviously Canton has some experience
with that with this time control
otherwise you don't you don't get that
yeah you don't get that quick yeah so
here white is veteran he's got some
attack going materialist I think equal
no there white is upon dama but he's got
all those active pieces and the rooks
yeah I'm going to initiate an attack
okay connect let's not trade it why oh
that's
okay so that would be a time win for
white and it's also a win on position so
magazine by nine points and yes played
by one g5 again which is kind of grouped
against 193 you don't take yeah how did
he lose two games yesterday I did not
some of the the whole stream I think he
lost against her lineage who played a
really strong game against him many
cards not said himself that is that he
played pretty bad this game but lineage
did a really good job of refuting their
look excellent and and he lost against
Wouter spell on what as a former
teammate of mine he was a top mate of
mine in the Dutch league when he was a
little kid like 12 or 13 really gone a
long way yeah 10 10 up for the no
champion yeah black is a pawn up and
there's not much compensation for white
I think but again yeah anything can
happen in this time control
yeah good night to the Bavarian Swiss I
understand you have to work tomorrow
yeah see ya next week maybe I also have
to work tomorrow
but my workday starts later yeah nobody
wants a chess lesson at morning time
European time if I'd say like 9:00 a.m.
in Germany
yeah the German people don't want to
just then at 9:00 they're usually I can
the offices or whatever I am so I
usually like that would work at past
time of the day you must start at noon
so I can easily stay on for for for for
a longer time so black has got the
better mind at the better structure but
maybe summer taking chances from wider
than that looks good now let me do a
countdown five five on Jack
it's our to do even knows those simple
simple math at that time he's up seven
seconds it's crazy
yes I'm doing chest from a time I don't
have anything else with it and decides
to do I'm young pitching and create
chess content lately I started the
streaming I always had a virtual channel
which was dormant for a while and now I
do those those streams ever it's very
enjoyable so and it just looks like a
very classical opening why does a lot
better here yeah the secon is terrible
and white has food
now the dark squares I little bit a
little bit if you what is see what what
who is see us lunches on Twitch all the
time I don't know how is anybody doing
full-time just streaming on nothing else
I don't know yeah Blake is losing on
time not he's crazy quick again yeah
there is a moment absolutely no
increment yet what's g5 that's crazy
before I'm I went to first started to do
chess real time I was working in a bank
in controlling yeah so mostly doesn't
look good twenty fives made if it comes
no yeah time he actually use the time to
resign summer colors are bad 12
what's going on here yeah you must like
you five seconds and then they have a
yeah what's going on here why it is a
piece of and it's called an attack but
it's it's the oddest position every eye
with the Knights on h1 to h3 probably
wide is it not better but it's just it
just weird yeah black black I was
probably easier to play what's going on
your head it's it's tough to from of
this and like it's a head on the clock
but okay white is ELISA draw now he
doesn't so there's a question how if I
know many title players who can make
money from chess yeah my making money
from chess and it's it's it's a matter
of definition if making money means like
real huge chunks of money I don't know
it's probably the wrong game
but I think it's it's it's possible to
to do okay I can tell from my own
experience in turn you can do okay
making money by plays better playing of
a game is certainly difficult like one
time again yeah it's it's mostly I was
the most professional players really do
a combination of of teaching
any game someone servants and makes them
what they do yeah I think here by the
way white Assam is having a nice
position but this is easier to play from
black I think Blackwood was throw and
throw the kitchen sink g5g for and so on
Group G a G 54 okay he's not throwing
the kitchen sinks okay so white white
was much greater there yeah but we you
have to I have to it's not all about
money no I did not say that it's just
like if you this is the main thing that
that you that you're after it's it's
difficult to do with chairs of course if
you yeah want to do the thing that you
like to do and then it's it's a strong
consideration to do it wow what a shot I
mean it's just just a little tactic just
a little tactic but it's so nice yeah
did you see that yeah
Bishop a5 it's just yeah no no white has
to trade Queens and the deads that's
basically game over can you afford and
help us health insurance yeah of course
I do is there's also no way to do it
without in Germany it's it's completely
mandatory there's no way without it
yeah I think why this White has a pretty
strong a check here and end a time and
the time f6 now is okay there is no way
that a human is going to beat any engine
in bullets yes
okay evade was a mouse slip here by
mindless quit okay
I look at 700 black it's not going to
survive that one I guess that looks
extremely dangerous me the rook has only
the square now all of a sudden there is
a there is a counter check going on
mater upon you mate
how he's avoiding than me that's crazy I
know it right now some time I went one
more time I'm sorry okay it's plus 14
from for the world champion at the
moment how long are they going to play
this match oh my goodness yeah why does
just a piece down that should be a win
for not just bras no definitely there
was a good game a black yeah I got a
Kings engine which gives Black Sun right
easy moves to make t6 but this is the
kind of this is the camp opening where I
want to always prefer black in this time
control it's just like okay the white
king
there it is going to be extremely
extremely difficult for whites to avoid
any sort of disaster
white is basically playing without the
King on the whole time
oh that looks like a shot but oh nice
nice one
Queenie Aiden are threatened yes always
a back rank mates and now it's reassess
cocaine right is probably going to make
it color always been a perpetual no
perpetual probably black wins on time is
now yeah he's clever really clever is
this this is kind of kind of really
strong hammered what worked him or what
Kansas to it just like he please
reasonably good moves compared to last
time control and you have to do it's all
relative of course but he also has a
street smarts yeah at the end you like
okay now it's just a long time and then
he's like yeah just making Hickey those
quick moves he's not sitting there
trying to make good moves when it's
completely inappropriate to do so so
yeah he can he can do the dirty I can do
the dirty game as well yeah what I mean
reasonably good moves
considering the time you know I mean he
really plays strong moves for this time
that that he has up fifteen now what's
happening here well swipe down six
seconds at a very beginning
it looks very good
alright but but time is not great young
pendent cousin one dead one question my
San Diego CA
do I have hobbies yeah not that much
actually and this is something that is
sometimes a little bit weird part was
when I was some when I was still having
a regular office job every basically
every minute that I wasn't there I am I
went into it to chess-playing making
videos whatever and after basically my
hobby become became a job I did not
really replace chess with anything to do
and what what's that White's King is
only for to get the mid of the board
that looks crazy isn't there some sort
of mate possible some made its black
managing to mate or not six mate
yes he managed it's nice I am your iPod
yeah I can remove the mouse sorry
shouldn't be exactly in the middle of
the board oh I was a blunder but
the its you know black has a really good
piece coordination and this is not so
easy to win even though it's a queen up
for two pieces I would actually like I
want rather would play black here
actually it's easier to play with black
ma'am and he's gotten some material back
like he actually has a safer King oh
okay
there was a good shot and yeah white
wins very nicely done
very nasty done I really felt that it
was easy for black but all of a sudden
great turn around
yeah this looks like a great attack for
white the queen evade made now almost
made threatened here oh okay
very nice defense by bublik extremely
good job here bye-bye hens are not just
getting killed there against this attack
and like actually has a strong counter
play now against king yeah thanks for
the following okay and white windows on
time very tough no worry i'm when i was
starting with doing chest fall time it
didn't feel like a risky move to me at
all but it was a matter of Bishop g5 was
winning new queen almost but this was a
matter of my person situation at the
time I mean I did not I did not to just
just leave the this job and ahead it was
it was just that the company that I was
working for basically shut down
gradually and it was a matter of not if
I had to leave but I had to leave anyway
it was a matter of just of time again
only had some say it leave quickly or
take take a longer time anyway
name started to get rid of all the
employees step-by-step I what I only did
is I said okay if you want me to go I'm
not really I'm not stopping you
let's see yeah I could have probably
stayed for a little bit longer if I even
wanted but I did not really feel like
doing it and yeah and at the time I was
thinking okay I'm going to try this out
and see if it works if you can actually
get some students and like you have to
have long days so filled with work and
it wasn't an issue at all
yeah White has a really great position
ahead of an imposition it was our eighth
time tom tells yes plus 15 for cousin
many games many games played already
very very good they're defending both
defending not really well really well in
this time control I would just get cheek
made it I mean like I take then
Whitehead look devastating and now yeah
black is probably better knocked down at
least the cons are just going to be too
strong nicely done by water but you lose
on time again
no I don't know if your Maya at all
absolutely not not at all never met him
never talked to him I have been to New
York once in 1999 but just for a couple
of days I really want to go again at
some point I can't see my favorite
German chairman chess player of the wide
width again won't you fight again we had
this this weird stuff on the board a
couple of times already
yeah it's like it's +17 now for for
Magnus ending right with equal material
where white is better because of the
brown structure if you can't really have
[Music]
if you can't really oh this is this is
really weird it's black fine now
probably is yeah this nightmare for is
so awkward to play against c5 is coming
white is always tied to that to that
pole under each one pretty nice
okay their cars go for the time this one
yes Masha my surname definitely sounds
some sounds polish and there is
definitely some connection there but
it's not like recent connection so
everything I know about my ancestors
ancestors well this is a tough word to
pronounce yeah like my friend could turn
down the game volume a little I think I
know if this stream started roughly 90
minutes ago 18 minutes ago I had a
restart because of them because of the
because of my technical issues
know what I was trying what I was trying
to say is that my grandparents they
already were born in and what is what is
currently Germany so it must have been
something really really overlooked yeah
the region day of question my surname
yeah and do young gusto someone but not
personally actually we've never we've
never met funny enough which is kind of
weird because I've been to Hamburg to
the just 24 studios but it's it just
never happened so what's what's going to
happen is almost plus plus 20 oh that
was a bad miss that was a monster yeah
he wanted to go Queen to e4 and played
Queen III this is not a bad line
actually I've played just my CL with
black it's a bit boring and it is
perfectly okay oh and how Magnus what
their peace with this yeah they're
playing rated and handsome is actually
winning some points but it's also
because Magnus is rating is so crazy
high and I think just Brasa
underrated not sure why actually but
think he should be higher on hands-on
from what I've seen him do it bullet
I mean 2800 is really high it's
hi I mean I'm not great at Borah chess
but I thought like usually floating
roughly 2,400 and this means that if I
would play hands and I mean Magnus I
would probably just by raiding I need to
lose every game
yeah like reading wise and this will
probably happen but this is pretty good
yeah if they would be like every game
that that will happen him now white wide
wins them just it's just just a rook any
more time you can always Oh Queen just
reverse them yeah that can always happen
now might need to try to win on time
yeah and that's actually going to end in
major Maine Maine next move Wow
yeah I mean sometimes they think there's
a question here how would you do you
think so fast as those guys and they do
think but not all the time yeah most of
it is just like reflexes you just do
yeah I mean this is pre moving a lot I
mean a lot thanks for subscribing
ecstatic broccoli that's a cool username
excited for the candidates yes I am I
really hope we're going to see a great
tournament and thanks for subscribing
eyes exactly exactly almost it
yeah I'm looking
looking forward to the candidates a lot
actually I'm I'm also traveling to me to
Berlin and I will do four rounds of the
German commentary they are on the site
looking forward to that
yes I played a match with Donovan forum
mr. John Bartholomew yeah oh no Chaz
raided I don't even know what that is
yeah no joke what are you doing you're
doing something I don't understand I'm
you to twitch please be gentle you have
played this match with with John a while
back thanks for subscribing it was good
good fun that match I lost it
due to the bullet mostly thanks for
hosting me so what is the score we've
got four in the room now from Magnus and
he's going for this wacky really
exchanged sacrifice had looks that looks
like and wines we had - resign there was
a pretty terrible position that then he
got very early on and we see Magnus play
Knight c3 Knight of three he actually
did this when he played in dying
approaches League yeah also did did a
brief match with John at the very
beginning I don't know how that ended
actually
yeah when we play a match Jonathan um
you and I it's pretty competitive
John is better in Bullitt it's just a
quicker and I know he's just better down
maybe it helps to be some years younger
but in blitz chess I think it's not a
big deal we are we're not not too too
far apart we hadn't over the board let's
game in London when we did the chess of
an event last year and this game action
won quite quite nicely I like the game
it was a good a good a good game
actually interesting you might play John
in in a match because I mean you have
sometimes it can be interesting because
people have very different styles but we
actually have we have a very similar
style playing style and this is this can
also be interesting so here that looks
like a white should have excellent
winning chances but again is a bit down
on the clock and we know how how quick
is oh no no not me nice gets a little
bit of counter play with this Queen and
he's four seconds up there that will be
then we'll be like yeah again very very
quick plane I have no idea if they have
some sort of agreement yeah best of 100
or something you have thanks for all the
support you on the stream it's really
great to see so many new followers and
some
some new subscribers is really great
yeah why Tia is a pawn down but that's
it's a good attack yeah it looks like
black is going for counter-attack but
now why does everything under control
and Magnus has got a couple of extra
extra minutes extra minutes extra
seconds extra minutes would be funny
[Music]
penguin
I am GMS and so on he would be an
interesting player to watch there as
well he's really quick I mean really
quick I play only played him once in a
in a bullet tournament and I was
completely winning in this game against
Bank penguin GM and routine but it
didn't help where he was so quick one on
time man and and very very clearly on
time I mean I had a completely winning
position but I couldn't simply I could
never make that smooth so got him the
score the score is now 52 would 228 so
24 in favor of the world champion and
that's a lot
yeah thanks for the thing for the
feedback on my games against the engine
with material arts it's it's enjoyable
sometimes I mean you you need to yeah I
mean need to be ready to take some some
punishment yeah and it can be
frustrating when you have those often
very good positions from the get-go but
you simply cannot yeah
win against the engine nice nice
technique then nice tactic Anna Boyd is
probably winning on time has alpha0
played bullets as having any any mobile
phone would beat you to shreds so you
don't need a half 0 and again he's
taking it 93g if another FIFA is really
pretty terrible but ok in this time the
time control or whatever you can you can
play anything actually here black with
all the open files it's maybe easier to
play oh that's a pretty awful pin of
that rook it's really tough to get rid
of it and now Queen takes problem I mean
so a little bit tricky to check on the
long diagonal it would be made like like
this yeah check but this f5 crazy crazy
it still continues yeah so Magnus had
won five in a row and that was one for
Eric so back back on the scoreboard oh
that looks good for white
really dangerous stuff about with
bishops yeah very appointed like here
pointed towards the King and the long
diagonal is definitely going to play a
huge role and wouldn't be surprised if
there would be some made on an aged 87
at the end and you're probably not yeah
it doesn't look like that that's going
to happen but the time is doing it is
really really too quick whose chest
brass yeah this is Eric where master
Eric hands on playing here against the
my champion it's strategically a very
nice position for black here it's equal
material like has excellent control over
d4 and Yankee plinking yeah I mean it's
it's really difficult to follow it
really is I mean I can I can see some of
the tactics that they play and so on but
it's really difficult to do and it's
it's really tough to do meaningful
commentary on it yeah I hope I'm doing a
decent job of pointing out your thing
and I shot there was might be three and
the bishop not taking c3 going for meat
that's made yes that's a good question
by Mick mcclain if I read that correctly
if I agree that chess world is
respecting fast chess move on recent
years if so do you think the trend will
continue yes absolutely that will
definitely continue I mean with fast
chess I'm not really talking about
discounters chess which is yeah it is it
is Chester rule bias there but it's
really difficult to judge it as or
compare it to at a normal game however I
think that we will definitely see more
Blitzen record and this is a something
that will definitely continue and I
think it's saying it's a good thing if
you if you look at internet broadcasts
let's say let's then stead say in the
protesting they play ten minutes to
second increment which is a very quick
rapid time control but it's so it's
reasonably good chess I know it's not as
deep as let's say yeah
yeah five hour six hour game but if you
broadcast it on the internet or people
still keep talking about bringing chess
on TV man who once chess on TV this is
complete nonsense
chess is perfect on the internet nobody
wants it on to me oh you watch TV
nobody does I mean it's we want chess on
the Internet and something something
like like the protest League format is
excellent I would definitely play in the
Pro chess leak but I have no team as far
as I know there is no German team and if
you want to play in one of the other
teams you need to have I believe some
sort of connection to them and sure I
mean of course you can't put it on TV
it's not that I'm against that but it's
it's not we don't have to ask ourselves
a question why isn't shares on TV your
chances an on TV because it makes more
sense on the internet and there are many
interesting formats that you could get
you could could could go for yeah who
say I understand
she says she gave away her last he said
1998 I actually have a TV but I don't
use it I have a TV set the only reason
why I keep it is because it could happen
that I would want to watch a soccer game
yeah and like if the German team is
playing or whatever I would sometimes
water Champions League or something but
usually I would folks yes in the chat
the folks yeah yeah I would watch that
but this is the only only reason for me
to to to start yet to switch on the TV
in the first place
so I'm I think something happened there
- um - Eric he also lost quite a bit of
time in that in that last game so we
don't know Magnus actually knocked off
so maybe he had to leave okay so how
does that how did that end yeah so the
final score was plus 30 59 59 and a half
against 29 and a half which is crazy
it's crazy so and I think in terms of
rating they both kept the rating roughly
yeah they both roughly kept the rating
so you know very nice job I'm a little
good entertainment even though I think
this time control is really really a bit
fast him it's really a bit fast but
anyway I think we had to think some some
some some good shed what am I going to
do is somebody
on that I could watch how does that work
actually there is this leaches TV right
we have some I am playing your fm words
I am which basically means that I could
I could play myself yeah it's not a big
difference yeah but so what are we going
to do um it's 1:00 a.m. on my end so I
can always on again actually he's
knocked on again what is he going to do
it's probably not a good idea to
challenge him right I can try it in will
not work yeah everybody will challenge
him but you you can try of course
rolling the word champion he's got a
million challenges right okay I'm going
to cancel that then it's not going to
work casual okay I can't do record rate
it yeah I can't nobody sees got some
game going
no they continue actually oh my god
maybe they maybe they just needed a
quick a quick break or anything why
aren't there any top GM's from Germany
anymore did you ever have some I mean
who know what's most wrong but it's
really difficult to get to the to the
absolutely highest level and it's um I
do understand in some way that most of
them most of all time people who are
really good when when they're young
really young
they have this a they have two options
they can try try for chess playing chess
or they can do something and it was made
on a seven but okay it's got no time at
all yeah yeah no Jo checking no joke
chess is right here they are usually
quite talented to those those those kids
with many things and yeah quite quite
often they would simply decide against
the chest Korea and do something else
and it's um yeah I understand what what
they what their rationale is
your hands probably to where they rather
had hedge fund managers than
stockbrokers and that's probably more
profitable or they cheated Volkswagen
yeah that's also yeah so six points yeah
I know we can continue to watch them or
do something else with it yeah I also
think that in terms of time control
again as mentioned what happened here
did he get some some time back I mean I
know it's tough to say but currently
this is not a really competitive a match
yeah cousin is up 30 points and he's won
the last six I mean out of the last 15
or so he scored 13 you know so it's it's
really him guys it's really not looking
good for black in this case oh yeah
hands on his black it actually looks
like some decent technical player wide
yeah considering the time control yeah
he's got he could have taken the night
but he will win win windows very very
comfortable him
yeah what I really liked is the is the
stream that Carson did yes a on the
protest League games this is really
really interesting I think to learn that
one what he was thinking about it
compare them cocaine you can compare
your own thoughts yeah thanks a lot for
subscribing crisp yeah it was really
extremely interesting at to to to to to
watch him play and listen to the to the
to the comments on the games I actually
I was sitting in front of my screen like
I do now and I wanted to do it do a
stream yesterday late afternoon and then
as then when I when I turned on Twitch I
was saying okay isn't that Magnus
streaming and okay I scrapped the idea
to stream myself so and just watched
watch this one a very nice position for
white Union on the deform night is going
to be very strong my bishops will be
very strong is a funny Queen sacrifice
it doesn't take it but that's going to
be very dangerous on the non-diagonal
like Queen G for coming and stuff
okay the Knights had to go for blockade
you know it will be in time egg again
mmm very very annoying for black 25
coming 9 f6 chick it was actually made a
made one g7
oh why am i awake at 1:00 a.m. Jemma
time and doing this dream right it's not
not like I'm doing nothing they answer
it's them it's the normal streaming time
I'm doing I'm usually doing the two
hours the two hours are over already
basically so I'm going in for some some
extra time no I've never been so much
afraid about about negative feedback on
on content that I produce I mean at the
very beginning when I started with my
youtube channel I recognized that some
people will complain about a lot and
it's kind of pointless to think about I
mean I always try to when I get some
criticism I really think about it and
okay it's really something wrong should
I do other things or things differently
I mean it's not like I ignore it but in
some cases you you just see okay this
guy just wants to troll and then yeah
when we have then I'm just ignoring it
so what's going on here that looks like
black should wind yeah and this is one
for handsome yeah they're approaching
the 100 game mark it's 65 were this
again and it takes you five for Gaza 31
for four handsome
who better put their did you have to
take one yet
what's that trapped I don't I didn't see
it I didn't see it yep when black looks
like she should let that black looks
like he shouldn't win but what all of a
son has drummed up real real real
dangerous countercheck and just looks
like it's at least a draw
yeah it is a draw whoa I don't have
draws all that off him how would i scoid
as i can tell you i would score
absolutely zero against both of them I
mean like one in twenty open a very good
day I'm just too slow and if they play I
mean I know you have you have if you
look at it and you have kind of there
with the cool-headed you you see
something that I come home yeah but
during the games
you're not seeing those under the
another stress of our time so yeah I
think white is not better here and
better on the clock as well this is the
thing this up like a couple of seconds
almost I absolutely love Gregg's videos
against all I gasps yeah I absolutely
love those I mean I when I
I had many games against all the guys
where I was really really angry about
this like flagging rook against rook and
so on but you know I still try to I
still try to be somewhat yeah to be
somewhat family-friendly yeah with my
complaints but Greg is just like firing
like it's just great it just feels great
yeah and I actually I had some some
games where the way I did the same kind
of cursing but I did not upload them I
mean I don't think you should put this
[Music]
on youtube
it's yeah I mean I think I maybe had one
or two videos where I was really yeah
but some of them actually did not upload
and then drag has some games the way is
like completely it's really really great
yeah I think I want some youtube myself
i muted myself yeah I did that once it
was a funny funny one
okay so what's what's going on here
let's have a look at the actual game
yeah Magnus has fantastic time
management this is by the way something
that is really really current also in
those matches how's that called nowadays
the speeches Championships chips what
what chess comm is doing those matches
where they start with five million three
million one minute yeah he's always
ahead on the conquer whatever happened
say is his head on the clock and we'll
play quickly no matter what and this is
extremely extremely strong especially
it's rated to be that good at a
measurement if you have a bad position
yeah so he sometimes has a bad position
but he's going to be head of the clock
at least the squares like plus 40 no 37
from Magnus 68 against 31
[Music]
well they're playing a real theoretical
stuff in somehow it seems like whitest
must have done something wrong because
black is a bomb kingdom on I wasn't
Mouse lip king me one night and there
was a bad bad mouse mouse lip here miss
click kinky one you get another kings in
Ian's predictions our hopes for the
candidates yeah that's a good question
of course I'm black black black looks
funny and a white king position looks
too bad but they defend really well
really well oh yeah a good streak affair
again getting three in a row
very nice yeah I think Ron Young is a
good pic he had a really good yeah to it
very good 2017 and he won't you brought
him I did not really look at the games I
have to say so I cannot really say like
you played great or anything the result
was very very okay he wanted in a
tie-break match but I have not seen any
of the games really that that Aronian
plate so if I say he played played well
it would be guesswork probably he did
play well but I didn't I didn't see it
yeah Mahmoud yarn off I think also did a
good job in Natal steel
he's definitely Wow I don't think Eric
will manage to to wind us at the end
because of the time very good very nice
stuff maybe it does then out of time
yeah Ronan started with the draw I had
it done I saw that one yeah everybody
has a has a bad game once in a while but
yeah anyhow I think with them yeah
almost all of the possible winners we
would get an interesting match I think
that was a big blunder okay for okay it
can happen of course whether they're
having more mouths lips now really yeah
the only the only match I'm really not
very enthusiastic about possible match
and I'm sorry for fans of kayaking but I
really don't like I would really
wouldn't like another match there with
kayaking I really felt that was a pretty
boring match
yeah Queen g3 is pretty much deadly and
black resigned yeah in terms of in terms
of playing style I think mama DRF could
be interesting is a vis very sharp
ambitious player I think I'm not sure if
he would be them GUI shook actually
would be an interesting change I agree
he's not really on many people's list
but I think he's he's the kind of person
that could actually do something
extraordinary for such a match I mean
he's famously somewhat famously yeah I'm
still a smoker and kind of yeah this is
his kind of bohemian to air about him
like with the polka play and whatever
and well if he's a shot at becoming the
chest will change and you don't know
what's going to happen I could do
something extraordinary Miami and put
himself this is going to be a win for
black on time mostly oh it's a drum okay
generally speaking um if somebody gets a
match even even if it's somebody you
don't really have on the Raiders being a
serious challenger to Carson they could
put up something really really yeah they
could borrow it can always happen
because this is them
this is them kind of kind of event that
is so special what is that
[Music]
she's sending them and thanks for
subscribing Aras Aras tutor yeah if
somebody gets to a match then they can
do something extraordinary can always
happen oh that's a shot and mate
no where's the mate where is the maid
there was no mate that's crazy
it looked like it looked like there
should be a maid time Eric no Eric one
time that's crazy
[Music]
yeah Marat Safin sham always has been a
fascinating player
I think he's mostly is he retired
nowadays I don't you don't see it much
in tournaments anymore
yeah thanks thanks to Aristotle on phone
subscribing and donating I think
actually for me our karana would be a
really good Challenger he gives now in
the games against Magnus it doesn't feel
like he's very intimidated and this is I
think very very important
well one thing that is definitely true I
wonder if people have the potential
challenges if they really have this yeah
if they really have in their mind that
Carson is a heavy favorite in any kind
of tiebreak I mean it always wins those
and I really wonder if they really take
that into account that they actually
maybe have to win the match because they
will lose a time I probably they don't
because I still feel there's some
randomness in them in the rapid chess
but I wonder if they think about that oh
there was a big blunder giving a giving
away the full look there will be three
sorry
Wow every woman one time that's crazy it
was down everything absolutely used on
everything
Oh God
yeah that's interesting yeah there's a
dimension that it's on the farm you play
a Cheeto nice to see where you thought
it was Magnus and it's funny I actually
had a game once on the ICC where I am
yeah basically said and in the comments
or in my mind in my my country that I
believe that the other guy was cheating
and I actually complained about this
this person Queen age one Erica killing
getting some good games him should win
this but it's got no time whatsoever he
may lose on time no way is going to made
now in like two moves
okay time and I played I played one one
guy where 30 was cheating and I don't I
don't know no no it was a I really am
send a complaint to to to the is SC
administrators and I later got the
message okay yeah okay this was not a
cheater
you were actually playing against some
of the best players in the world he
didn't tell me in the name but I was
really thinking it was cheating and I
mean if you see some of the games that
calls in place and this is I mean he
sees he's the best okay but no it could
also have been like what number two and
number three it's really sometimes out
of out of this world what they want they
managed to do in in blitz chess in this
game I lost so badly with some computer
issues and they absolutely
assured me that it wasn't a wasn't an
engine but rather a very strong player
playing it was still a kind of efficient
thing because that account was was
shared but anyway yeah so sometimes you
think there is cheating involved it was
just a very strong player playing maybe
on a on a or in account that he's not
usually playing on so what's going on
here black should be okay but most most
of it him is about the time yes or no
people's now it's it's a bit difficult
because there is some noise also those
checks by the side most material up yes
sharing accounts is not allowed but it
happens all the time
happens all the time
yeah we have here clearly above the 100
100 game mark in this match and they
don't seem to stop they don't seem to
stop what I wonder is actually are there
other streams I into a tank it's also
streaming this oh yes I wonder I wonder
actually if when they are actually
located Magnus is probably Norway he's
been had handled the cameras house or
apartment or so yesterday so it's it's
pretty late and homey already I don't
know where the herring is located at the
moment could be an advantage if it's not
as late but they probably have rather
irregular sleeping patterns anyway yeah
it was good for white might should have
pretty strong and taking chances and the
the black background is also quite weak
Nancy for headsets pretty awful shot you
cannot take on d3 last night a 3-chain
wins the Queen and other Queens
immediately lost yeah nice
counter-attack
I'm like really look good for white if
you ask me but then over image offered
canceled what's going on no they're not
stopping
ting once won an algebra game while
making a phone call this is crazy that
looks like Oh Bishop a5 is coming it
looks like win for white it's easy that
helps that happens a lot
it wasn't that easy to win actually if
you if you have to do it in seven
seconds but I should change endo ten I
don't know what is he doing actually he
is dreaming
[Music]
yeah I wonder I mean I will not be on
for that much anymore it's like more
than two hours already but I wonder what
to do I mean I don't know they might
they might continue until till whatever
yeah I don't even have one down how do I
get actually how do I get there I had
this jima sauna no I I don't you do that
all that much why this Dimas page he's
not in my friends list or anything you
know it's a bit easier if I have them in
the list down they continue to play
right they will probably continue this
however it doesn't look like they're
going to like they're going to stop yeah
I think he's also probably cubed sing
and my score is zero one day I lost the
lost one I can try I can try to play him
what was the time control
a blitz rating totally sucks why is--why
set featured over mine okay
you can't rhyme I don't think he wants
to play
mm-hmm yeah I kind of understand I mean
you don't have this soft now that you
can watch the one champion play even
though I accompany understand that it is
after like 100-something games that you
kind of feel okay you've seen enough
yeah I completely completely understand
is SE cannot play in the first place
okay so I'm on for more than two hours
and I'm thinking what to do I mean again
they will probably play on forever and
yeah this is this is I am completely
understand that you maybe can can play
Magnus a bit later I have two challenges
still on yes team is only tournament on
ditches would be interesting I agree but
many streamers now have those exclusive
contracts so it's it's probably not
going to be all that easy to to host him
very easy to house on chance on Kong
probably um yeah so let's say I could do
like let's play like for half an hour or
so
play some play some viewers yeah if you
if you like but not much longer it's
really really late and have to actually
get up reasonably early tomorrow morning
so got some some blitz challenges oh
that's awesome bullet oh my god I do it
[Music]
[Laughter]
this is totally impossible for me and it
doesn't really matter how bad black
players I'm just going to do this on
time this is full pre move the whole
time actually have the wrong sitting
position for this it's impossible to
play quickly this is this way I was just
sitting here completely relaxed yeah
from what shake oh my goodness
I cannot do that I have a way what do I
have I have half a minute challenge okay
come on I just want to show that I'm not
that slow I mean it's not that I'm super
quick but I can I can play reasonably
fast I want the Queen okay yeah it's
it's it's it's kind of okay yeah I give
you one minute and that time controller
feels feels kind of appropriate
[Music]
thanks for the follow
[Music]
now how are the trick it was a trick as
well
Wow
okay now I'm not not anymore I have many
other challenges but so we're not three
plus three that's kind of weird
five days what five days is crazy not
five days let's go for it
you know it's not playing this guy dance
beneful white but I think I think I'm
okay yeah didn't see that coming
my queen doesn't have that many squares
how do I get down not sure that was
clever
going from Queens right
would you 6 looks bad I'm kind of losing
my threat here a little bit Nydia 3
chick is also coming
Quincy I'd ever covered meet funny made
group she 3 ok 1 rematch and a bullet
game this is kind of ok it wasn't a
really good game a good move trading
them giving black all those dark squares
not really nice idea by me ok wow that
that that wolf that came that came out
of the blue ok good game here by project
bad one so we have unlimited whatever
let's not do that
who else is on there 2 plus 2 is kind of
a weird time control yeah let's do it
I think for roughly 20 more minutes
feels kind of slow right after the
bullet craziness not trying to ask a
question about this even though I'm not
really threatening to take still like
that I think that is a fairly easy
position for white to play yeah he's a
ticking you for I have this I don't know
if this is actually good yeah but
probably it is 95 has to be played and
it looks a bit awkward oh this one it's
a bit surprising it's made but laughs
this is the Queen yep that was a blunder
there what is that
1.5 plus 3 that's crazy and three second
increment one minute 30 plus 3 okay I
had to accept that yeah it's it's a time
control then I never played in my whole
life
absolutely never and so this is also a
way to getting him can its castle
that looks fine yeah if I blunder f5 so
probably not
by the way I should I probably mentioned
this earlier but I should do that again
I have absolutely no clue why I don't
have this emote yet for for subscribers
absolutely no idea because I have
submitted it and yeah quite like more
than a week ago and I don't know why but
it's not yet
it's not yet been approved it's so I
would surrender this is not yet been
approved by twitch so it's not yet
usable by the subscribers I think it's
kind of weird that they take such a long
time yeah they're probably quite busy
but I don't know I mean it's there's
really no reason I came hmm it looks
like you could could create some funny
made or so no designs I can just take it
to of course next
yeah thanks of the game nummy that was a
really weird time control king of the
hill oh and you're trolling me with
funny changes I don't play king of the
hill jokey oh they came more for the big
streams 150 people is not big yeah okay
I understand but still
and the cat's defense phone you don't
play I play this you change variation is
a pretty good line doctor disrespect
just 350k viewers I still don't know
this person so I don't know what does it
what does his dream
he cheated on his wife and took a break
okay okay I try to do h4 h5 him yeah I
thought this is a good way to do it yeah
if he plays Bishop f5 I have 926 that is
the worst pawn structure ever he streams
P OBG okay I'm not a cool person hey if
I don't know what it is I probably can't
can't figure it out if I if I take about
I should have played h5 myself that
would have been a lot better actually I
still have a pretty good position I
think but it could have been a lot
better if I would have played h5 myself
that would have kept us Bishop out of
the game oops I player unknown
background hey I've heard about that him
[Music]
I mean I know that it exists which have
never looked injured
EDC pawn looks very strong
what is that time control and playing
two plus one okay it looks like there
could be an Arabian made in there
somehow I am probably not immediately
but where is this going
I think I can I can do this maybe I'm
now try to get a passed pawn this one
yeah I think I'm taking this and
probably d3 then huh can also check but
that doesn't help
that's a good move actually
[Music]
somehow it feels to me that I'm not
playing this particularly well I have
this this notion somehow like I'm
blundering something or overlooking
something
yeah the REA bein made it's my favorite
chick made and always has been my
favorite made but I only I only some
years ago discovered that is actually is
called the Arabian maid
okay thanks all the games ochio Joe kill
Jack good game yep so team o89
the tech it's a really really weird time
control team or 89 I'm going for a
somewhat quicker time controls there at
the end during my next project on chess
about after the e4 repertoire or are you
still referring to the e4 repertoire as
the next project
yeah two plus one bullet but she was all
playing as the problem
okay wait doesn't that work
the glitch no what okay cool breeze one
plus one after the four betray no I
don't know yet what I'm going to do
after that and very likely a black
repertoire a wide repertoire based on a
on a mainline like e-40 form is really
really tough actually to do it's it's
tons of work and black repertoire has a
bit easier
hmm so I probably try to be a little bit
[Music]
yeah I try some easier project and we'll
do something with black but I don't know
yet what it is and what is going to be
[Music]
there is a likelihood iam that it's
going to be something with black against
you form I didn't play this right now
this is bullet okay it's okay
I'm thinking mmm great yep and then all
of a sudden what about yes and the e4 e5
repertoire for black would be
interesting I mean I mean this is this
is definitely an option 94 as a tech
tech tech 94 24 Bishop f5
yeah before if I threw black definitely
an option I have to have to think about
a little bit then my main incentive
would be to but but if I do that I will
definitely look into those lines again
that I presented some years ago I also
think they are a very valid to be honest
think they all came but no I will
definitely not to do that shiorin
rook takes c3 maybe him no yeah cool
breezes completely killing me I mean I'm
doing this very bad life
really I completely forgot that it is
bullet and I'm completely out of sorts a
very cheap trick
what's going on here damn bro that's
weird and I have not come to that to the
Spanish in that old YouTube repertoire
this was started in 2012 or something
2013 and it never got to that stage
[Music]
there is nothing against the room and
nothing against Italian game simply
never never got damn this baby Queens
doing him looks a bit odd yeah I think
there is more than one horse genetic I
think folks yes right I'm not sure that
c4 c4 c5 fir is has that name yeah that
looks like an end game away from playing
very very conservatively
okay now I get your F phone yeah I have
slight chances here on the light squares
night is a bit better than the bishop
but it's probably a draw and I think
what you're saying there in the chat c4
c5 sorry d 4 d 4 d 4 D 5 c4 c5 I'm sorry
it's a bit late already
what you've heard to add some austrian
attack or austrian defense I think this
is actually not really good but but it's
ok it's actually oh this is
non-incremental have to speed up and a
long time and what is actually quite ok
is d4 d5 90 of three c5 that that is
very ok actually I have played that in I
have played that in in tournament chess
and one against a grandmaster with it
with black you played it once 1 once
everything's cool
ok one more game against crisp atsuhime
I think d4 d5 so for seven c4 c5 is
probably a bit much I have some doubts
about that hmm
is that good this is line should still
work right
96 is the usual way to a few dad
normally you have castled and not knight
on c3 but I think it still does work
but Kenneth opening is that d4 d5 f4 f5
the double duck I know it sounds kind of
kind of weird double duck yeah here if
he takes it I've got the other night was
hanging but I have queen h5 if he takes
it with the maid threat on f7 and at the
same time the bishop was hanging yeah
here after capturing on age six there
was Queen h5 here him taking our screen
edge 5b should be six and that should be
to win yeah here I wanna party six and
blacks position is pretty awful a simple
idea would be Queen f3 next like this
oops
get going for this you know now I have
to trade now I am unfortunately
I can this is a simple way to do it
okay okay here I am comma F for cavity
form that makes some sense I'm I'm a
clean poor knob which is actually fairly
a good result for for black after this
opening it could be even worse
okay that will be a good spot for the
king
ooh this is really really not very
exciting I've won appalling Blake is
trading down yeah but well I have to
play along I don't really have much
choice
so how'd you do this night 2 D 3 maybe I
should detect this pawn it's the
weakness so attacking it makes a lot of
sense
yeah thanks to Jean Jacques our vanilla
just said he will neither leave the
string hanging in there for almost three
hours I would also quit shortly it's
really late on my end to 2m and yeah
like it's roughly six and a half hours I
have to get up again
yeah he activated his King but I had to
take that with a check and huh that
looks I wonder can you somehow create a
mating net here looks like it looks
close to made like king C to a 4 B 3
made
huh okay king c2 Knight takes f3 and a
for maid and he cannot cover b3 maid
yep mate
I can he can check me okay no wasn't
wasn't able to cover cover it okay so
one more game is down any challenge by a
subscriber Lord Kinbote a let's play one
more game
and then I'm calling it quits for
tonight they are still playing I cannot
believe it
crazy crazy after this game I will I
will take a quick look
just enter Scoy I really have it really
amazed that they that they saw
let's stop playing okay
after Carlton got 100 okay
102 42 54 okay
so somehow I didn't play it like I
usually like here in l a-- coins somehow
i have this e takes pollution and set of
C takes hmm well it is kind of okay I am
I don't think I'm in trouble but still
so I have to put in the pawn to d5 I now
have this this poor information here a
Bishop f5 was better Bishop f5 rook
moves Knight takes e5 was possible I'm
so threatening this long no not anymore
okay let's try this bow 97 so I'm
finally completing development and I
think I'm okay actually a little bit
less space but my pieces are all all
working like same like this some
pressure on to deform yeah it's probably
people the bishop wanted me to looks a
little bit odd but okay maybe this to
unbalance things a bit now Knight f4 is
coming 154 hyperbola games no I mean I
definitely don't have no stamina for
that um hope a penguin gem is hosting my
stream Wow
why is he doing that
that's good so uh I can probably play
150 out of the bullet games but not like
at the moment I think in the middle of
the night it's not going to I wouldn't
be able to do that simply lack the
stamina so um can I win this pawn it
looks like I should be able to do so if
I've is a little bit disconnected from
white skin but I don't see a way to do
it I mean the other question is like
really should you play 150 hugger bullet
games or is it maybe a little bit too
much anyway
it really feels like to be long 150 so
how do I get something going here night
to be 5 or something I don't really see
I would like to get more pressure
against this night a 2 2 ticket yeah why
does trying form white is tried for this
b7 pawn but I'm trying yeah and at some
point you probably have this heaven just
have some you just have some problems
with your hands yeah absolutely
yeah like the mouse and you're kind of
probably screwing up after after this
time and anybody else on yeah maybe one
or two more games yeah boy agent I have
a couple of games against them already
what is that probably some sort of
bullet match at some point okay
yep got luck
but it's that three-minute yeah let's do
this
I actually played this line I know it
looks a little bit odd but actually I'm
not too bad so just simple
centralization and then see what happens
yeah maybe this threatening see for me
okay it's it's it's not difficult to
spot but 94 is also interesting as an
idea
[Music]
[Laughter]
now they don't don't insult people on
the chair please
okay so c4 is the idea it's not hmm
okay so what are you saying
you're saying you don't care right okay
I'm not sure this is the best move but
it feels like it's possible I thought
that ultimately this somewhat somewhat
weak King position could help maybe I'm
wrong there
and it doesn't matter maybe it doesn't
matter actually but you really he's much
better developed unfortunately yeah it's
not that great honesty
surprising I thought that this must be
must be weird what he did but it's not
so bad in fact like it's fine now he's
definitely fine him
I'm not sure it's probably equal
yeah maybe black is easier to play here
in fact rook the aid for night before so
bit it's a bit awkward yeah down night
night c2 is a pretty substantial threat
not to noise hmm that's weird
that's very weird I felt like I should
have a good position but it is not not
the case
rook e8 yeah it's a strong move that's a
strong move if I move the bishop is
going to go up t1 and my development is
killing me
it looks like it looks fishy this
position looks very fishy 96's Kutcher
no not that good who
hmm yeah it looks it looks wrong okay
this is good Jim I don't have a check
and roopd several he plays Bishop f6
problem
Jim that doesn't look good nicely done
very nicely done
okay I'm kind of curious there I cannot
believe this this any good yeah thank
you and I don't want to rematch there
are so many people challenging um that
looks kind of weird what's going on in
the church you don't behave anyway so
like one more game and then I'm I'm
quitting this anyhow it's it's too late
I let's do this come on that's like yeah
maybe I had c4 earlier possible so I'm
going to play here one game against our
Jian's chess960
always tricky
that wasn't so great this is this is
gone okay
that was a bit short no draw now has a
really high ready corner let's do this
who is no draw now okay
Clyde's been ages
agents ages since I looked at it five
six or something or did I already screw
up this aha
very weird very weird the whole way
white plate does the air forgotten I've
got forgotten the serum
okay I've got some play against e3 like
c4 I can yeah good couple of options
might be six I can go it just takes you
three of course it's possible what is
what is he doing this one okay I'm going
for going for the ending basically if I
come to I can't I can just take take me
six at the end man it's a little bit
awkward okay
can try this it's a little bit off site
in this piece it's free zero and we have
to have to speed up at some point okay
let's have a look at this
hmm it looks a bit odd what I did okay
how does he cover that now see form it's
not not so easy to cover I came robbery
look see four winds and c7
[Music]
yeah I'm hanging on as good as I can
Roxie 548 again maybe I am cause it's
never going to make any single in
accuracy him
[Music]
okay anybody know this person still
alleged account off I don't know hey and
there are those games where you feel
like it's useless I didn't actually want
it to do that okay so it's there one
more game might even you don't know
are you one more game coffee that's a
final game for the stream how more than
three hours I didn't want to do that
anyway is he going to play or not
doesn't seem to be the case okay I
[Music]
didn't actually did actually read what
was said there in the shed
okay so let's go for one Trump I know
this is a fun game and it's need some
sleep I tried you take the black center
we see form
oh yeah there's a couple of things I
can't this is also looking very
dangerous actually try to push the pawns
you can take what Queen B 3 rupee one
that will be quite some pressure on the
B file quite quite quickly
I take this how is he preventing made
here probably not and Knight takes c6 is
continuing the game but okay so it was
the final game for the stream I'm going
to wrap it up here after more than three
hours it has been a lot longer than
originally planned so I hope you enjoyed
the stream pretty long one we had quite
a number of games with the word sham be
playing outer No it said outer bullet
hyper bullet are turbulent okay anyway
hope you enjoyed it I only played a
couple of games at the end and I'll be
back soon enough thanks for watching bye
bye